mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
start with a right triangle rotate and
translate it as shown
mark the overlapping region between the
two triangles in blue
the question is what is the ratio of the
shaded area in blue
to the entire shape's area
to be a little bit more precise suppose
the original triangle is abc
and it's rotated and translated to the
image
of a prime b prime c prime we want b
prime to be exterior to abc
mark this point as d the question is to
solve for the area
of b d c divided by the area of the
entire shape the solution in this video
is by nestor abbad
and i've provided links to the source of
this problem in the video description
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem to get
started
notice that angle b prime c prime a
prime is equal
to angle bca because they are
corresponding angles
of congruent triangles this means
dc is equal to db
next angle dba is complementary
to angle dbc but then
angle bac is complementary to angle bca
because triangle abc is a right triangle
we have two angles that are
complementary to the blue angles
therefore
these two angles in green will be
congruent to each other
this means that db is equal to da
from here we will construct a
perpendicular from d
to the side bc mark this point as
f we will have the right triangles
dfc and abc are similar to each other
now dc over ac is equal to 1 over
2 which means that df over a b
is also equal to 1 over 2.
from here consider the area of triangle
bdc
it'll be equal to one half multiplied by
bc multiplied by df
then consider the area of triangle abc
it's equal to one half
multiplied by bc multiplied by a b
if we divide the second equation from
the first we will cancel out the terms
one half multiplied by bc
this means the ratio of the areas of
these triangles
is equal to df over a b which is equal
to one over two
now triangle a prime b prime c prime
has exactly the same area as triangle
abc
thus we have the same ratio for the area
of bdc
to the area of the triangle a prime b
prime c prime
from here suppose the overlapping region
bdc has an area equal to x
by the ratio of these areas the
remaining area
in triangle abc must also be equal to x
and then the remaining area in triangle
a prime b
prime c prime must also be equal to x
we can thus calculate the ratio of the
shaded area
to that of the entire shape it'll be
equal to x
over three x which is equal to one over
three
what's remarkable is this ratio is the
same
for all such right triangles that we
overlap
in this fashion as long as b prime is on
the x here
we have the same ratio of the shaded
area to the entire shape
as one over three and i think that's
quite beautiful
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you